hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot
gameplay over the last few days we've
been diving deep into XCOM twos war of
the chosen expansion and all the changes
it has to offer chief among them are
boss fights with the chosen these three
highly powered persistent bosses that
you'll run into throughout your campaign
recently we got the chance to take on
the assassin a chosen that specializes
in close quarters combat and guerrilla
tactics with her melee weapon after
defeating her we also got to use her
weapons for ourselves in combat you can
see all of that in the following clip
but in the meantime be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and stay tuned to game spot
for more XCOM - content throughout this
week
the target is not
[Music]
we'll pay dearly for your positive right
back
never commit to strike unless you are
truly ready
Roger the device appears to be some sort
of psionic capacitor transferring
tremendous amounts of psionic energy
directly to the chosen restoring them
these things don't die
my ammunition is almost gone
ready to engage
[Music]
and now
hostile neutralized do we have a
munition available
going on
[Music]
the enemy should fear us
I go as ordered
you have the power
thank you the enemy has reserved twice
but this next time
I require an in issue we can no longer
hide
and now
[Music]
how style target down could use some
ammo over here
[Music]
on the move get them
I am Alabama I'm hoping that's a good
thing yes the regeneration process has
been interrupted readings on the
capacitor indicates it has become highly
unstable and let's target that chosen
with everything we've got
ready weapon permanent covering now
is possible to fight another on equal
footing how accelerating for that you
have my gratitude you shun the outside
world and yet here you are caught in the
same trap that's all the rest
moving out
[Music]
I need to reload as you order
there will be no reconciliation for your
kind beeps lair fight and die with honor
or simply die there makes no difference
to me
and you have to do better than that
[Music]
Kill Confirmed
Oh
you will never hide from me
moving to designated position you know
that was good
target neutralized
for hiding it over
damage
I can handle that
yeah seems doable
not too shabby we have confirmation
mission accomplished